how are you chef teah hello there rich
how you doing when'd you first hear
about it or did you were you just
getting a call yesterday and you're like
holy cow what the hell you know I'll
tell you a funny story I actually was
picking up my daughter from school
yesterday because I got back I was an
Ann Arbor on Monday there for some
meeting some business hmm and I saw
coach Harbaugh there him a little bit
but got back on Tuesday hadn't seen my
daughter and what ten days and went to
pick her up at school at five o'clock
and said the only good news don't work
next to fight and so as we were driving
back I got a call from somebody I said a
is something going on with Josh
McDaniels and I said well it was she was
bad fighting a couple of weeks ago but
not now and they said I'm not so sure
about that and I said okay and so you
begin to make some calls you get more
information next thing you know you find
out yes he has was about to tell the
cult's that he's pulling out from head
coaching agreement they had and so I
literally got home and went into my
office and at 10 o'clock last night went
upstairs to say get out to my daughter
she said dad I thought you said about
their words the next couple of weeks so
that's what that was like doing yeah man
that's the life of an NFL insider that's
the top of the profession like you
brother so okay what what what was
McDaniels told in that room but between
craft craft and Belichick did they did
they tell him he's the next coach one
bills done was it they can't do that
because it would be a violation of the
Rooney rule
okay I mean but listen if he's gonna
stick around the biggest thing that came
out of that was I think that they they
expressed how much he means to the
organization how big a role he can have
in the future things he could do what's
sweeten your contract now and again when
you're doing this to a man who already
had questions about whether or not he
should go who didn't know what it would
be like to move to a city who didn't
want to have to move his four kids who
didn't know the connection you'd have to
the GM or the owner I mean there are a
lot of questions he had and the Colts
did their best job to answer them I mean
the second meeting that's the reason
that Jim Irsay came to Foxborough to
meet with Josh Daniels
McDaniel's because he was not convinced
at that point time that he wanted to go
he needed to be sold more and I think at
the end
the Patriots recognized that and from
the time they got back from the Super
Bowl they they acted upon that and they
made him feel wanted and loved and
appreciated what monetarily yes
absolutely read this contract and so you
can do that and they did do that or
they're gonna do that but they have an
agreement to do that so that's going to
get done and they're gonna keep him in
place d the issue with promising him
that he's gonna succeed Bill Belichick
aside from it being a rule II rule
violation is the fact that do any of us
know how much longer Bill Belichick is
in a coach for well that's part of the
question about what happened in that
room did Belichick give an indication no
I don't believe that was the case okay a
Bill Belichick wanted him to be on that
staff and and so I don't think bill
knows how much longer he wants to I
don't I mean it's a tough question like
he's gonna be 66 years old next season
the one thing I could tell you is I
believe he's got beyond this year left
on his contract so whether that's two
years three years I don't know the exact
answer I really don't I
very few people outside the crafts and
Bill Belichick do they keep that very
closely guarded but my understanding is
there's multiple years left
I would guess two or three mm-hm and so
Bill's gonna coach this year and I think
when you get to be that age which is an
age that most coaching legends didn't
even make it to and he still got all the
energy and excitement and enthusiasm for
that job that anyone half his age has
yeah it's a year-to-year proposition and
you see how you feel after each year
could he after next year say I'm done
I'm moving
yeah I guess he you know he could do
that could eat coach in New England
three five yeah I mean anything's
possible and then that's why also I left
the people you know josh mcdaniels
committing you know coaching suicide you
know not give it what what does that
mean you know what a year or two from
now there might be a team that is in a
situation where josh mcdaniels is the
right guy for them at that time you
can't you can't judge how you're feeling
in the morning of February 7th I
I will beg to differ with you there sir
okay I will beg I mean come on so you're
telling me that no team is ever gonna
hire him as a head coach ever again
outside New England um hold on of it let
me just let me try and not stutter no
team outside of New England will ever
hire me as a head coach again I mean
what why would anybody go ahead and do
that Adam why would anybody go ahead and
trust this guy I mean what happened
right there
a must they sign a contract on it look I
as you know I'm not one of those
broadcasters that I what I'm saying is
absolute of course that could be wrong
but again he has been courted before and
spurned other teams and they've
continued to come back to him so do I
think that there'll be another team
listen again as we're talking I think
the chances are he remains in New
England the chances are he remains in
New England long term so it becomes a
moot point
yes but my point is I think he's 41 I
don't know rich five years from now how
many times your team's in a head
coaching bind and if he's doing a great
job you tell me five years from now
there's not gonna be another team that's
interested in hiring up it's Ahmad one
of the top play callers in the game well
they better get some sort of that's fine
you know fine blood blood oath I mean
right I went off let me ask you this
Adam Schefter here in the Rich Eisen
show chris ballard said that that that
Andrew Luck and Josh McDaniels never
communicated I'm floored by that what do
you think when you hear that Chris
Ballard and Josh Medina was never
communicated no no Andrew Luck and Josh
McDaniels never communicated Sean
McVeigh and Jared Goff sat down and
broke down every snap of his career
before they before the rams went down
the aisle with him were you surprised
but Sean McBay was out of the playoffs
josh mcdaniels it was involved in a
Super Bowl run here so that I don't know
that didn't surprise me one bit that
surprises you rich yeah I mean if it
does not surprise me well what are you
hearing I know what morts reporting what
are you hearing the same thing about
luck shoulder
listen again shoulders are serious on
quarterbacks now again if you watch
Chris power today
he tried to reassure everybody that he
believes that Angela's gonna be fine
he's been given assurances from the two
doctors that he worked with that things
are on track but I think when you're
talking about a quarterback in the show
we don't know for sure
we just don't know and I could tell you
that there are people out there that
have concerns about it now
I'm not telling that they're gonna be
right I'm just telling you there are
people who I have concerns about it so
we'll see how that plays out over time
look everybody wants him to come back
and his presence is significant for that
organization for the NFL without him
they're kind of doomed but they need him
back I think there's a general sense of
optimism but it's not absolute at this
point I'm like boy no doubt he's back
he's good to go
they're ready to have Angela back I
think there are some questions and
depending on who you talk to those
questions are more significant for some
than others I have a shefter man Adam
and I know I've got five minutes left
with you so I want to hit a couple more
things now with McDaniels in the fold
how does that affect the craft Brady
Belichick meeting that's about to be
another room where it happens Adam I
don't I don't know how that plays out
look I think I think the bottom line -
that would be dollar checks expected
back rate is expected back I'm sure
there are some ruffled feathers there
I'm sure there are some issues to work
out you heard Robert kress say last week
that you know that's not been an easy
year yeah I don't know these the depth
and specifics of what each man feels
about each of those issues and and I'll
leave that to them to figure out but
again what do you think the fallouts
going to be there I expect them all back
next year
so what could it be you know certain
well and that's why I thought first
blush McDaniel stain is way for Kraft to
basically say I've got the guy in
waiting in that meeting but then we hear
Belichick was in the room with the
crafts and McDaniels to try and convince
him to stay this is amazing man I
haven't seen anything like this
certainly for a team at the pinnacle of
the profession but this is unbelievable
Malcom Butler playing to all this what
can you tell me about the Malcolm Butler
situation from Sunday all the way to now
well I'll say this to you rich and again
I know people are skeptical and you're
gonna hear my explanation and be
skeptical and that's fine I'm not
telling it's true
just when I spoke to a couple of
different people who have said to me
that it was a strictly performance-based
issue that he did not play well this
year did not practice well this year and
they didn't feel comfortable using him
now was there something else you saw
Malcolm Butler come out and deny that
and I recognize that you think that a
man a player who played over 97% of the
snaps this year who was a one-time Super
Bowl hero with one of the greatest
defensive plays ever made in NFL history
no less postseason history could just be
benched at a time where the Patriots
really needed him and their secondary
was leaky and they could not get the job
done I get all the optics of that I do
I'm just telling you what I've been told
by two different people
it was a performance-based issue believe
that or not yeah it's tough to believe
God played every snap against
Jacksonville right I mean he got him in
the Super Bowl if his performance waned
within the bye week so horribly I mean
ah that's a head-scratcher brother Wow
yep it's uh again III pass on what's
past I know that so deep last one for
you
you know Ballard says the rivalries back
on and you know what everybody's saying
that this is deflategate revenge do you
put any anything in that because to me
the Patriots want McDaniels back
regardless of which organization he's
walking to anyway I think rich I think
that's the best way of saying is that
the Patriots knew that they needed Josh
McDaniels that they could have promoted
shadow shades offensive coordinator but
they knew they were better off with Josh
McDaniels as the offensive coordinator
do I think Dax piece the main reason
that they went after him as far as it
absolutely but do I think in the back of
their minds that Kraft and Belichick
aren't snickering okay that they're
pleased that they did that I'm sure that
that is a passing thought and similarly
in Indianapolis if you watch Chris
Ballard who did a great job
with that press conference was spot on
and his assessment struck just the right
tone I thought he was very diplomatic
very cordial very assertive until the
very last statement when he went the
robbery is back on and walked off the
stage now that's the way to finish press
conference okay so I think that he's
disappointed and Earth Day he lost his
head coach at this time the fact that if
the Patriots throws a little bit of
spice on to that rivalry but I don't
think that was the driving force behind
what the Patriots did nor the
disappointment the Colts feel but it's
probably in the back of the minds of all
the parties involved once again great
scoop Adam great scoop and so folks can
download your pod today correct that's
it mr. Dawkins got a motion key talking
about the Phil dole to Philadelphia
victory what a minute that City was
pretty interesting why not man that was
unbelievable and Jeffrey Lurie as well
great stuff as always brother love you
thank you appreciate you love you buddy
okay that's Adam Schefter
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience